today i'm going to our local bar i live
in the hood in london so
it's not that nice this is what i look
like now um it's bad but i'm about to
glow up hold on
okay um i never said it would be that
good of a blow up but i'm kind of in a
hurry
i'm going to show you guys the little
bar at our town oh gosh
because remember i do live in the hood
this is not a nice neighborhood i go
through this tunnel to get through the
to the bar you really think about your
life decisions when you come back let me
tell you especially when it's this long
at night oh no
but you know you get through it okay
this is the little bar here
it's pretty ass i'm not even gonna lie
it's like very small there we go
okay wait so we go inside
you want to film you okay
what's up
[Music]
oh yeah
what brought you to the pub tonight
sick thank you i can't be sick hey
someone appreciates that here
no it's something you see yourself are
they yeah
yeah it's like you can um so you film
and you can actually lost pictures what
what take a number
a picture
oh yeah we can do a video
these are i met these guys at the bar
because i'm corny yeah it's a video
hello
what's your name are you from london
yeah
what time does it close time i think 10
30 right in terms of you you're enjoying
it
there are these hot guys in our building
we're too scared to talk
okay guys so this is why
we don't judge a book by their cover
they were not as hot as we thought
they were cute from a distance
shopping okay like i haven't yet she has
a boyfriend she's about a winner
um
we get there
and i'm just telling a story i'm a chit
chatter
i like to chit chat have a good time he
just starts touching my leg i'm like sir
i just met you
i don't
i don't even remember what your name was
so we had to we had to bounce
it was it just got real weird real fast
yeah
gabby kind of flipped a [ __ ] on him
well he was being rude he was being rude
i just can't like the second i heard him
like say something about me i was like
i'm either gonna beat his ass
you dyed your hair i did i love it i
don't know why it takes me so long to
notice you're the first person to do
this
i am so tired of these men having two
children always
okay guys
we have this to ourselves
tripping all by myself
don't want to be
all by myself
[Music]
all right guys we're trying to make it
to the bar
we got lost a little bit but yeah
you're from america or canada america
yeah
boston
no chicago
california
[Laughter]
translated
it's funny how we speak the same
language but it's so different sometimes
it's going
well you can change it
it'll say it on the train
yeah
i don't i have no idea
uh we were going to
this land like yeah we're in castles
it's going to be a bus or a taxi it's
not going to be
oh okay we follow the jubilee line sign
there's buses or taxis outside
just left
you
i don't know where we are now but
we're walking to the bar yeah we're
walking because we're thinking about
cardio because oh my gosh
yo there's a bar
in pizza hut in the uk
do you guys drink that much
i made it into my telephone booth it's
like one in the morning
and we're on i don't even know where
we're at but we basically got lost
because the train
stopped at one in the morning but look
at how pretty this is look it look it
and gabby's with me she's behind the
camera hi
man i don't know this is cool it's like
one of those random nights
that you you kind of aren't doing [ __ ]
and you randomly decide to do something
and everything goes wrong but it's
really fun 100
yeah so so
what is that that's big ben baby that's
solid and i i don't even know
she
we went to a bar the bar was closed yeah
by where we live yeah and she's like
dude you want to go downtown i was like
sure yeah i just i was thinking it's so
sad i've lived here this long and i
haven't done anything and i'm really
tired of doing that
yeah so now
i'm on in the middle of london at one in
the morning sorry mom don't watch this
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah we went to bar number one
it was okay it was kind of dead
so
now we're trying a different place
hopefully we can get there
is this a casino should we go gamble
yeah is it open
this is my first day gambling
i'm ready i think i'm going to end up a
millionaire we'll see all right how much
are you up now
40 pounds there's two types of people
no
to like preface the slot machine thing
every time i played i've lost so this
like listen i have no self-control so
i'm going to play
it means nothing so you're up did you
have a good time i had so much fun you
look very cute
you look you're looking very mighty sexy
[Music]
i don't even know these people's names
what are your names
what are they yeah what are your names
i'm max max nixon
[Music]
in like what like five minutes they'll
get you
only that was in real life
well i could lose 60 pounds like that
how much money did you lose or when
i lost 40 pounds oh i lost 40 pounds
nice good job
all right
look at the difference in the uk
mcdonald's yeah we got
the same stuff and they're on the same
side by the way right the burgers are
not the same size they're quite
miniature
the burgers are smooth
all right okay well so it's like if we
were to go out friday night it's like
oh my god what else what is going on
this is chinatown by the way and this is
the famous gay boss
sorry sorry
wow
okay those people are yelling i don't
know what's going on
so update i did not in fact make it rich
tonight i just lost 35 dollars pounds
so it's like 50 bucks i think
it's sad
it's okay though
i'm gonna keep going
[Music]
how's the slot machine treating you
did you win
you won i think i won 22 pounds oh my
gosh
oh wow
how much money did you put in
i like literally i'm coming out with
like
this okay if i if
if it couldn't be me i'd want it to be i
believe now that i'm up
that's what i wish i did
okay
yeah she's smart like 13 more dollars i
was up like 10. mcdonald's on me baby
i just want a mcdouble oh i got you i'll
take a large fry oh large
soda
you can see by some of
i can't wait to tell my dad about this
all right to the nice um
men who got us to the bus stop we
appreciate it
um unfortunately you're never going to
see us again
you guys are super cool amazing people
amazing people but they're not even none
of this yeah like we're
respectfully you know but it's hard
because it's not like
guys will insist yeah i'm doing [ __ ]
well they wanted to help us though yeah
look at it
appreciate it thank you yeah you know
what
i just put it out there just in case
thank you yeah thank you so much
these guys these guys brought us to the
bus stop
it was a tour of london basically
we had a great time really good time
i think that they followed us into
mcdonald's though only a hundred percent
so this i was like you know you guys
don't have any food we met them by hand
coming up to the first guy coming up to
pearl saying
are you afraid of me like
that's such a weird opener but i'm
smooth should i be i'm smooth right
smoothly i'm smooth so he's like are you
afraid of me and i was like i was just
looking to cheeks your hands
are cute i forgot what i said yeah you
said cute i didn't mean it though and he
said oh i like you
yeah
i mean he was cute
yeah he was
i was like i thought he was cute at
first when i got like a better
another
vlog yeah so anyways the kind of second
thing is cute these are short
but
anyway
nice meeting you
thanks for getting it
we were lost i know we said we'd get
dinner we got there black yeah we
i said i didn't say that you said that
well he asked i just said yes because i
wanted him to get us
whoa